i think this collaboration is really
important because it challenges
us academic exchanges expose
you to different ideas people just
learn from each other we've been able to
have some quite uncomfortable
conversations
because i came from there so i know how
they work
although we sometimes have different
opinions
we are really good friends i think
collaboration is essential to science
and the greater diversity of people we
collaborate with then the greater the
benefits i think it's as simple as that
[Music]
i'm heather viles i'm professor of
biogeomorphology and heritage
conservation at the university of oxford
my name is chilene gua i am blunt to
dunham academy in china dunwang research
academy
is responsible for looking after
some of the major heritage sites in
north west china
and the team we work with are a group of
scientists
led by professor chinglin guo our
research
mainly focuses on the conservation and
preservation of cultural heritage
and studies the destruction on
sites by wind and drain and we're trying
to investigate whether
planting things around them or enhancing
the natural vegetation
can help protect them against further
deterioration
these blocks have been made by the dun
hang academy in china
we use this 3d microscope to look at the
surface
of the blocks to see what happens over
time
so this afternoon i'm going to use the
machine to measure
ultrasonic pulse velocity on
my earthen cubes i'm very lucky that
within my group i have hong jiang
who is chinese and has very good
connections with
chinese colleagues i'm a translator
i'm a coordinator and also i'm a
researcher
we started this collaboration actually
from 2015 because i've got
quite a lot friends who are working in
china
i said to my friends i said look
obviously you have those amazing
heritage sites
but my boss professor has availed i
think
she started this kind of concept for
for example like learn from nature
learn from the past so i thought why
can't we just work together
our collaboration has lasted for almost
10 years you know we started from
several
international meetings we then began to
exchange
our researcher so we talk reasonably
often but at the moment we talk
mainly through hong kong so sometimes
hong jenny and i will be in a meeting
and we'll be discussing
you know something to do with the
experiment and i will say
you know off the top of my head oh hong
could you ask
our duncan colleagues about this she
will almost instantaneously get onto her
phone get onto wechat
and within often half an hour we have an
answer to the question
we're looking at this very surface of
the earth and cube
and we can see the bits that have been
um subjected to the harshest conditions
have become
far more rough whereas at the start it
was very very smooth
is the culture of doing science
different between the uk
i believe there are quite significant
differences yes
some of those i think are generational
so i think if if you were a scientist in
the
starting off in the 70s and 80s in china
then their their systems were quite
isolated from the west and i think they
had very specific
viewpoints i think there are some
differences
really especially the way of thinking
scientific problems i felt
the science in the uk is more like
philosophy
chinese scientists are more focused on
solving
practical problems that's quite unusual
in britain the science is often quite a
long
way away from the the practicalities
another
huge difference between two teams is
is the way of expression you know
western people always dare to express
their opinions while our culture tear us
we should thinking more before we talk
the
really obvious cultural difference that
sticks in my mind is just the difference
between
work and home i think they found it
rather strange
when they came as individuals to spend
time here for a year
and they think i think they felt that i
was rather cold because i
would come to meetings with people but i
wouldn't invite them round to my
house and you know i like to have some
down time
so after dinner was like right so you
put your meat in to work out what's
happening tomorrow
yeah that that's why you say why i said
that
to jenny probably i i feel a little bit
sorry because i know for jenny
who's uh growing up here uh probably
wouldn't
like uh do that kind of things uh
after outside the working hours but
that is very normal in china are there
any more examples of things that you
have to tell
jenny or heather or you know english
researchers um
when they told me to sit in the van
because it was too much work i'm telling
you not to get offended by it
yeah yeah yeah and i mean in china for
carrying out those field work mostly
just a man
she already noticed when jenny was there
those chinese guys they thought oh she's
a student
firstly secondly she's
a girl and you know under this
very hot weather it's too too tough for
for a lady they just try to
for example like treat her like a sister
try to protect
her but without realizing properly that
could be a problem in a western country
this is an environmental cabinet and
it's used
to simulate environmental conditions so
we're simulating
what happens in winter so when it's
really cold during the night and then
warms up during the day
chinese people are very hospitality
uh the each time we we don't need a
pay like a food accommodation
i think after so many years has already
changed the something so when they
when chinese friends i mean chinese
colleague
uh come here uh each time
has tried to organize a nice
meal for them just to show
her you know appreciation
so i think somehow by the collaboration
i mean people just uh
learn from each other so my english
is not very good so you have to
say your english is not very good yeah
not not
good enough
[Laughter]
many challenges and difficulties occur
in such a
transnational teamwork such as
difference
in language time lagger
cultural highway there is difference
we can overcome compared with the
benefits
from our collaboration one of the areas
that we found to be quite challenging
is deciding whose name gets on to the
paper that
comes out as a result of the experiments
we're doing
and what order the names are in and what
we've discovered is that chinese
practice is quite different
to to to british practice and i think
it's a measure of the success of our
collaboration that we've been able to
have some quite
uncomfortable conversations and come up
with something that
works at the international agreed level
of
kind of research ethics although we
sometimes have different
opinions we can research
quickly because we have the same goal
which is to protect the cultural
heritages
which belong to all of mankind
the big sort of political goings-on how
do you deal with the fact that they're
there
and you do talk about them at all um
that's a really good question i mean
politics is always just
very narrowly under the surface my
experience is that it's really hard to
talk to chinese colleagues in any
meaningful way about these things
even when they're in britain they're
quite reticent
about being being open and it's quite
interesting for them to be sat in our
lab group when we're having some
political argument and you can tell they
feel quite
uncomfortable and i think when we go to
china we also feel uncomfortable
because you know we see all the cameras
taking pictures of
every vehicle as you go along motorways
and i think each one of us as
individuals
has to navigate that we are
comparing p sorry i said p we
again because we are comparing
sorry i think there's a real
challenge in trying to actually get to
know and understand
each other and the way that we've really
i
think got round that challenge is
through spending as much time together
as we
as we can and also
luckily perhaps sharing a good sense of
humor
and that would be my tip for any
collaboration actually
is that if you can laugh together you
can probably
start to really understand each other
well the basic
prerequisites is trust when you
have doubts you can ask questions
but do not rush to thank the other
team before you fully understand
if i was going to advise colleagues who
are wanting to start out on these
collaborations i would say be humble
i think one of the dangers that i've
learned and this is through
collaborating with people anywhere in
the world
is do not spout what you think
is something really sensible in the
first five minutes
always listening to people trying to
be humble and say i don't really know
what what do you think
is a much better way of of of getting a
shared
understanding of things
perhaps the best benefit that i've had
from this collaboration
is when i go to china and i have to give
a lecture and it has to be translated
slide by slide into chinese and it takes
forever and it's really stressful and at
the end
i get so many really interesting
questions
and i've just been exposed to a lot of
different ideas and viewpoints
you know heza is very clever and so kind
it's very relaxed stay with her and her
teams
she's always about able to put
herself in your shoes she's my really
friend
during our corporation i've absolutely
loved collaborating with them i mean
they've
they've shown me sight that i would
never have seen otherwise
they've just given me experience to work
with different people in
in different ways i've i've really
enjoyed it
for me i think firstly even i'm working
here
i can also contribute to
those historical sites
in china so this is a kind of you know
the feeling feel very happy
about it